how do you describe tonight I mean we're
here it is so surreal it's so
overwhelming in the best way there's
Lord and Miller over there I've got my
family here all the little ones are with
me it's just this is a dream this is
like it's not it's not often that you
get to be a part of something like this
so I feel I feel incredibly lucky how
does it feel different because the first
one it was like oh we don't know what
it's gonna be goes on to win an Oscar
everyone loves it how do you describe
the feeling of going into this second
um honestly much like the feeling of
going into the first I think there's
there's certainly a level of confidence
that I wouldn't say wasn't there before
but just a level of knowingness uh we
have the same incredible incredible team
that worked on the first film plus some
new amazing additions uh and I don't
know I I have that similar feeling of
like I get to be a part of something
real special and real cool that has
resonated with me so deeply that I do
feel will with most others fans of the
first movie and people who will just be
seeing this for the first time so that's
the thing I mean you see all these
little kids here too dressed as Gwen
what does that do to your heart oh my
God it just makes it beat a million
times per minute it's just
I don't know I
I kind of feel my wish I had when I was
10. I definitely would be on this carpet
in a spider going outfit for sure
I love miles and Gwen so much but I have
to say one of my favorite Dynamics also
that I've seen you do is you and
Florence Pugh in Hawkeye thank you Lynn
are we getting this Duo back together oh
my God I hope soon because that was too
much fun
now Haley I gotta ask you when are we
going to the era's tour and can you take
me because I can't get tickets
oh my God
[Music]